[Aplausos]
sólo para pedir ayuda con algo y es que
me levanté en la mano de algunas
preguntas que voy a hacer al principio
se siente identificado levante
hacemos un ensayo rápidamente déjeme de
la mano del ok es el público que
necesita muy bien ustedes tienen que los
consejos funcionan
funciona en cierto que muy bien quiere
ustedes han escuchado en su casa y hablo
ahora con los adultos que están
trabajando quienes han escuchado cosas
como amigo o mi hija no es bueno en
deudas
ahora de la mano los que tienen deudas
usted cree que los consejos funcionan
bien es materia esta esta conferencia ha
propuesto que voy a poner el tiempo así
que este espíritu es muy corto
básicamente lo que quiero es contarles a
ustedes cómo reconocer tu grandeza y no
es un consejo realmente lo que vamos a
hacer es cuando te digas cómo reconocer
tu grandeza voy a dividirla en dos
partes muy cortas la primera parte
introductoria le vamos a decir al esto
que está ahí la primera parte es podemos
reconocer y reconocer tiene que ver con
darte cuenta porque tenemos un montón de
comportamientos automáticos cosas que
hacemos y no sabemos por qué las hacemos
voy a arrancar de las más simples hacia
las más complejas
me pueden ayudar a entender y este lo
han oído varias veces porque hay
personas que cuando van a dar reversa le
bajan al radio el carro
porque tengo algunos empezando por mí
quiénes son los que le van
para ver mejor el perfecto
y algo más
para escuchar el golpe es como llegar a
mi casa en la tarde y haber debajo un
perfecto ahí le di a la sala y quedé
bien la verdad es que no sabemos pero
están muy serios así que va a cambiar la
pregunta me pueden ayudar a entender por
qué
en estos días voy con mi esposa en el
carro y estamos buscando una dirección y
me dice bajini que es por aquí me pueden
ayudar a entender que tenía que ver ver
la dirección con el radio pero están muy
serios voy a cambiar la pregunta me
pueden ayudar a entender que tiene y por
qué uno a veces le dice alguien visto
podemos hablar sin claro cuénteme para
que se quitó las gafas entonces ayudar a
entender eso no
la verdad es que estamos bien los de
comportamientos automáticos y estamos
llenos de comportamos automáticos porque
ya no nos damos cuenta de por qué
hacemos lo que hacemos y este es el
caldo de cultivo para que aparezca algo
de lo que les voy a hablar muchísimo hoy
que son los virus mentales y los virus
mentales son pequeñas rutinas que los
autos sabotean el problema es que no
sabemos y no sabemos que no sabemos que
tenemos virus mentales yo quiero hacer
un recorrido rápidamente para que
aprendamos a reconocer un virus mental y
al final para que sepamos qué hacer para
quitarnos un virus mental y quiero saber
si les interesa esta mini clase con lo
que le interesa déjeme ver la mano ok
perfecto una última pregunta y el
trabajo de materia
quiero que ustedes se requieran alguna
vez como una persona que no le convenía
maxthon el orgullo de la silla sólo que
muy bien a quien usted le advirtieron
que esa persona no le convenía vamos
sólo una mano por favor ok ahora se
puede levantar las dos tiene ustedes
después de que les advirtieron con más
ganas se metieron con esa persona al de
la media de la mano eso es
comportamientos automáticos esto es lo
que no hacemos no nos damos cuenta y
aquí me quiero presentar mi nombre es
víctor se ve genial de considerado un
millennial de pelo blanco
creo que nací en la época viendo un
montón en esta época y ahora que nos
conocimos les dije cumplo 50 en febrero
pero llevo como seis meses celebrando
porque llega la época de la vida que la
vida me está pareciendo divertidas am y
que creo que estoy empezando a tener
cosas claras y quiero de una época de la
vida donde queda menos tiempo delante de
la atrás y de eso se trata la charla de
carlos mayores es para que no se sufran
tanto la vida para que se lea gocen más
empecé montados con reconocer entre la
universidad de 15 años y mucha gente hoy
el día me hizo igual pero no sé por qué
no me decían eso en el colegio me decían
que era un intenso y que era un canción
porque preguntaba mucho hoy en día le
llama interés por el conocimiento pero
ha iniciado toda clase de matoneo y
tenía apenas por ser inteligente así que
algo 17 me gusta decir que soy egresado
de la javilla en la universidad mediador
antes de que me echaran por bajo
rendimiento porque no me puede bien
porque ha destruido carrera cuando no
estaba preparado para estudiar carrera y
luego escogió una carrera que me gustaba
más estudiar negocios y se estaba
estudiando el ocio si estoy me quebré
y la conferencia este el tema es que
había tenido un fracaso académico y ha
tenido un fracaso en los negocios pero
yo me considero un tipo inteligente lo
mejor cada fracaso en el amor supongo y
no quería cosas por eso así que empecé a
preguntarme por qué hay personas que le
salen bien las cosas y no son tan
inteligentes por lo son y hay personas
que no nos salen bien a pesar de los
llamados inteligentes y descubrir algo a
lo que llamamos virus mentales así que
esta búsqueda me llegó a este cuadrante
que les voy a presentar a continuación
cuando hablamos entonces de reconocer tu
grandeza vamos a empezar a conectarnos
con la segunda parte de la oración que
estuvieran de ella pero antes de empezar
a entender dónde viven los virus
mentales y cómo no sabotear quiero que
entendamos como aprendemos cómo aprender
ser el humano el primer cuadrante lo
están viendo arriba a la izquierda hacer
las cosas que yo sé y yo sé que yo sé
estamos de acuerdo por ejemplo la
palabra del 5 sé que existe la tabla del
zinc cuyo idioma esté en la tabla así
como me doy cuenta sino por unos 5 5 por
2 10 y hasta ahí todo bien ahora hay
cosas que yo no sé pero yo sé que yo no
sé también por ejemplo el idioma alemán
sé que existe el idioma alemán y tengo
perfectamente claro que no tengo ni idea
del problema porque me doy cuenta que no
sé
es el cuadrante de las cosas que yo no
sé espero que me doy cuenta hasta ahí
vamos bien pero se complica en el tercer
cuadrante que es el cuadrante de cosas
que yo no sé yo no sé que yo no sé
aquí se empieza a complicar y este es el
cuadrante de los vídeos mentales y los
virus mentales son cualquier rutina que
te haga ver la vida como una combinación
de cuatro palabras y quisieras si no les
molesta que la repitan conmigo estamos
como te hacen en la vida como difícil
y escaso sufrido y luchado
vamos a realizar rápidamente y conseguir
dinero es
fácil de acuerdo qué difícil porque
plata no hay a mí me da pena con ustedes
pero mientras crecían mamá me llame
había dos o dos iglesias de una vez te
digo no hay ok y me decía cosas como
usted cree que la plata crecen los
árboles usted cree que el dinero me lo
regalan usted cree que las identifica
con la derecha perfecto que está muy
bien muy bien y también veo que hay
personas que dicen no yo nací para más
nadie nació para mí
6000 millones de personas en la tierra y
calcula probabilísticamente con un
producto así quedan a 60 millones de
personas que podrían hacer más con este
gordito que ven aquí pero decidimos
sufrir no lo ok difíciles caso sufrido y
luego te dice por favor cuida el trabajo
porque el trabajo no hay poder y de esta
manera nos hacen ver la vida como algo
difícil escaso sufrido y luchado son
pensamientos de escasez y lo que te
quiero decir es que la naturaleza piensa
en términos de abundancia algo tan
simple como fecundar un óvulo la
naturaleza nos impone y con las calles
es manda millones de espermatozoides
para presentar un solo óvulo así que las
actuales piensa en términos de
abundancia y tenga en cuenta que cada
vez que estamos aquí nació metido un
problema votar 1 millón del manicomio
sea muy delgado tenía cola pero yo fui
el que sobre el niño y desde ese punto
de vista está probabilísticamente yo soy
un ganador
no me enseñan a pensar de esa manera
llegamos al cuarto cuadrante y cuando es
que yo sé sólo que yo no sé que yo ya sé
lamentablemente en colombia si tú eres y
en latinoamérica si eres demasiado
seguro de ti mismo calmas
lo han pensado
yo dicto conferencias a veces en
empresas a veces en universidades como
me invitan y también asesora empresas y
luego por ejemplo cuando llega alguien
nuevo una clase y se presenta a
propósito tenemos un alumno nuevo y como
se presenta el nuevo buenos días me
llamo visto un amigo más espero aprender
muchos de ustedes o sea se presenta como
101.000 de verdad pero qué pasaría si se
levantara y dijera buenos días quién es
el mejor estudiante aquí y alguien
levantara la mano yo dijera sin agua
que se está creyendo para hablar de esa
manera estamos acostumbrados a que la
gente ya como que aído víctor aislados
con la ayuda de dios bien estamos
tumbados montón de cosas pero es porque
nos enseñaron a sentir pena por nuestra
grandeza y lo que te quiero decir es que
nosotros tenemos grandes en nosotros y
llegó al último cuadrante y como es que
yo ya sé sólo que yo no sé que yo ya sé
la historia de la piedra es que arranca
en la universidad de 15 años mensajes de
la universidad terminó estudiando cosas
que me gustan porque fracasan en los
negocios y no tenía nada que demostrarle
a nadie creía en mí no solamente perdí
mis bienes sino que en la calle de mi
familia y quedé con 300 mil dólares en
deudas en el año 2002 a mis 32 años y
hay gente que me ha dicho he visto les
tocó arrancar de cero le digo de cero no
de menos trescientos mil dólares y ahí
lo probaran acá lo que tardaría dos años
en pagar las deudas y luego prosperaría
mucho más que nunca antes pero porque
había cambiado mi manera de pensar y
había entendido que no es un pecado que
seas bueno que creas que eres bueno y
que es valioso pero te enseñaron eso
enseñaba a sentir pena si tú eres bueno
por esa razón mi mensaje para ti es que
no tengas pena de reconocer tu grandeza
empeoren el vínculo tenemos nosotros en
nuestra cabeza y se llama no le voy a
poner la vocecita y que es la vocecita
un parloteo existencial que todo el
tiempo nos habla y nos dice que las
cosas nos van a salir mal o no recuerda
lo que nos ha salido mal
voy a quedarme callado un momento para
que escuchen sus voces citas
vieron
era la que decía yo no digo una
no le salió una desgracia y la vocecita
es la causante de que la gente no se
siente en primera fila en una
conferencia que tenemos bien presentada
en primera fila que bueno ya no son los
speakers y las familias explicas lo
tenemos que presentar a la primera fila
porque algo que la vocecita le tiene
pavor a dos cosas o trabaja 24 horas al
día para dos cosas una vez quedar bien y
la otra es evitar pedernal y por eso
hace validaciones infinitas lo hago lo
hago intento lo intento no me arriesgo
le creo no le creo que está bien o está
mal es correcto o incorrecto imagínate
el drama que eso puede causar cuando uno
va por la vida en una entrevista de la
pasión para salir con alguien sabe lo
que esa relación es nuevos será que le
gusta es que no demostró que era que
piensa que sí que va a pensar de mí la
vocecita es un dolor de cabeza porque
todo el tiempo la vocecita para que se
hagan una idea es la causante de que la
gente se caiga en la calle y no se asome
ustedes como calle y los babies salen
serios caminando y como las dos cuadras
viraje seculares medio pero ni de
riesgos se van a salvar porque el
primero muerto que humilde
y lo que les quiero decir hoy es esa
vocecita que todo el tiempo te palotes a
lo que te ha salido mal y que advierte
de lo que podría salir del mal no es tu
alma y nuestro ser es un efecto de
validaciones externas que hace el
cerebro pero tú puedes aprender a
reconocer la diferencia y la diferencia
está en las cosas que sabes que no sabes
que ya sabes para terminar mi padre se
fue de este planeta cuando tenía 20 años
mi papá tenía algo que nos tocaba tanto
de que el consejo me contaba una
historia
no reconocen el estilo
teníamos problemas y siempre sea papá
porque no al grano se echaba un cuento
larguísimo y al final me da una
enseñanza mi padre murió yo que después
de 20 años quedé casi que al frente de
ese año tenía como una misión en la vida
y era como honrarlo a él y cómo hacer mi
adulto a los 20 años como ser el motor
económico de mi familia de los 20 años
pero luego empecé a ver que todos
cuentos que me han echado
la información que necesitaba para ir
por la vida y cuando a los 32 años
quebrado pensé que voy a hacer
escribir una conferencia y cuando fui a
escribir la conferencia de repente me
encontré que estaba escribiendo una
historia para el final dar una moraleja
porque yo ya sabía de conferencias solo
que yo no sabía que yo sabía que se
había sido la herencia y el regalo que
me había dejado mi padre y me preguntó
cuántos regalos tienes había cercado de
los cuales no eres consciente que estás
grande y poderoso él es ya lo mejor te
han dicho que te debe a penas una
invitación para ti es tal como arranque
te invito a darte la oportunidad de
reconocer
[Aplausos]